what can we do in our last hope fails
[Music]
you must discover our last hope
sailed this see before you
in search of an end to the beasts that
have hunted us for generations
[Music]
or so we thought
when the dragon rose into the sky like a
phoenix
blazing in flames of agony
but our hero never came home
only the storm the beasts the
unshakeable dread that something had
twisted and turned
storm swirls
in this tower like a shrub
the dragon may be dead
the precious
[Music]
you will fight for every step
reached the tower learn what became of
our warrior
face what he looks within
[Music]
when our last hope fails another shall
take its place so long as we have breath
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
boom
you're awake
hi there
whoa take it slow you don't want to
start bleeding again do you I'm Wallace
I wanted to see you ask the commander if
I could
Oh commander Ford she's in charge
Oh commander Ford and mr. Rigler found
you outside they brought you here but
they said they said Marc was it coming
back but he was and every wine the
commander said you should come see her
when you woke up she's in the room down
the hall
she'll find a place for you everyone's
got a place Celia
[Music]
well well look who's awake
I figured you for dead rigs that I
barely pulled you out of that mess
I'm commander Ford
this is my base and you friend are an
unexpected guest it's my job to know the
kind of people I bring into Ward 13 we
haven't seen a living soul on that Shore
for weeks you will tell me why you were
really out there or we'll let the root
have you
no one has been in that tower in a very
long time but you've got no chance of
getting there in this storm
truth is the ward has been cut off we
have to block the gates after we dragged
you in the root are everywhere but now
that you're here I have an idea I'll
tell you what you want to leave you'll
have to do something for us first first
we need power that storm knocked out our
reactor recently whizzed enough power we
might be able to activate another way
out of here the reactor is on the lower
basement level there's a stairwell that
leads down to it get it running then
come back here because I'm not losing
any more of my people today we already
lost a man down there a few days ago I
suspect the root have found a way in go
check in with Riggs
about your Glade I don't imagine your
fists will do much against the route you
do this for us and I'll make sure you
get out of here
[Music]
[Music]
are you where you're scaring me where
the hell did you come from nearly scared
the life out of me no one else wandering
around down here uh and you're not from
around here are ya
names ace i scoundrel you looking for my
friend les he said he was coming down
here to fix a few things that was days
ago I wouldn't seen him since everyone
else root him off but not me I think
maybe he you know yeah yeah maybe come
to think of it that's probably what he
tried to do anyway I mean I'm sure we
found some quiet place to sit things out
you know he'll turn up so you ever start
a reactor so you figured you'd just come
down here and wing it lucky for you it's
just the press of a button on the
terminal above us would have done it
myself but without knowing what might
come sniffing around with the two of us
though
maybe we got a chance okay so I have an
idea you go upstairs and start the
reactor I'll help you kill whatever
comes our way you probably need a weapon
huh let's see if I can find you
something
[Music]
[Music]
there that should improve our odds get
up there and start the reactor
[Music]
[Music]
get up there and start the reactor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I gotcha
[Music]
oh did it saved your ass
- hey don't feel bad we're live and the
powers back on
I call that a win you guys go check in
with board
I'm visit my shop sometime yeah I'll
make sure to give you the need some help
out there discount
[Music]
[Music]
feels good they have some light around
the end
you're risking a lot for folks is all no
stranger